[Applause]
this is Kreuzberg it's a section of
Berlin but like everyplace else is just
exploding with life and energy you know
you got dreadlocks people wearing eye
patches people with parents parents with
eye patches parents with dreadlocks
that's Berlin good to see you it takes
him seven days to get through an airport
metal detector good Todd couldn't talk
everybody just sees me and they want a
piece of me that's right
hi how are you I came all the way up
from the marina see you did I have
something for you ah that was scary the
way you said it tell that I'm quite
nervous anyway story ha ha I found an
error an error show you really do see
the show that's so now that's show
Friday you said that the chilly stuff
the chef it was 5,000 times harder than
Damascus Tabasco sauce the noodles were
5,000 times harder than Tabasco sauce
but Tabasco sauce is 5,000 Scoville and
what he ate has 20 millions 5,000 at
times 5000 is 2,500,000 so again what
should have said 4,000 and they are
taking him said so but since we don't
have the time I found a lot more arrows
arrows
thanks to fungal of mistakes you find a
lot of mistakes on our show
yeah and you traveled two hours to give
me these mistake it almost mean three
hours from Bavaria and you in
tournaments we mean business
yeah you do mean business yes you stay
right there yeah can you come here for a
second yeah I want to talk to you about
your friend I'm really worried about him
yeah hey it's all good no one gets hurt
oh good get him medicine okay we'll
rejoin him now well this is fantastic
thank you very much
listen it's called the riddlin 35
milligrams very high it's what they use
on circus elephants
you